мораторій на експорт українських сіл
і на 10 років став причиною ручного
скандалу
become a переплелися і бізнес-інтереси
продавці у лісі
обожнювання екологи з барахти карпати то
плани українського уряду від риму тетчер
лоху фінансово допомогу європейського
союзу ми проаналізували головний страх
та українці курей азіз касу ваня мораторій
на експорт лісу в євросоюзі поважають
наявності skoda українським лісам створюють
на продаж даровані
а корупція в системі лісового вас за
дарства безсистемне вирубування її на
ефекти вниз право охоронної системи
адже суть нестриманого планування
зоряного не лесів є пропан у якогось
хлопця що європейське до sweet захисту
лісивши за петром кай європа шкіра
адже фінансово не я по видно програма
єврокомісії ідеї в Україні ж висимо
років внаслідок поки не травня мораторій
на документ дар його труна не промислів
асті україна
вона місяць мусаві і перейти в тінь
квітах європейських експертів ви їсте про
фактично монопольний ринок колиска з
агенства 1 сильно встановлені then it
руйную лісу господарство продавати та
дерево але через офшорні по соратники
анни напряму покупок та axor вигляду
євросоюзі
ситуацію ви провалу боротьба з корупцією
вузли ж не подарунки для дерева величезних
підпілля ств зменшення мити на імпорт
обладнання то доступ до дихав акредитив
na kuhne хвіст вони транш макро
фінансову допомогу з 600 мільйонів євро
віці україна відриваючи я з косою мораторій
на експортна біля труни і дарвін і
аджі winpe рушниця угоду правильно тури в
ліс
вручені взагалі дні києва рахунок закритий
дерпі удар бюджеті гребля чи йому
тельних заявку Верховної Ради для здачі
національних інтересів з косого ти
мораторій може побут і вкрай складно
контрабанда українському лісі ж перед
варила україну над жерло зірвані для
інших crying ви про ось ці зможе
тільки брати бас корупцію щось нове
закон зручності і до забави я живу
сергієвих вусик і абсолютно локальних
епр візерунках ринку ви хде
закон зручності європейських краєм за
одного розумного лісу до малювання то
охорона тисняві для син ж шляхом я з
пропану та пітти та україні